certains lots de charcuterie ou de
fromage sont sans doute à l'origine de
l'épidémie de listériose qui sévit en
france depuis quelques semaines une
trentaine de personnes ont été touchées
et sept d'entre elles sont décédées des
suites de l'infection
malgré les enquêtes épidémiologiques qui
se poursuivent
l'origine exacte de la contamination n'a
pu être identifié ce matin le ministère
de l'agriculture a été obligé de lancer
un appel à la vigilance et à s'expliquer
après la fuite dans la presse de ces
informations
isabelle sabouraud sans précédent depuis
le gouvernement a révélé l'ampleur de
cette épidémie de listériose qui a
entraîné la mort de sept personnes
depuis novembre l'alerté sanitaire avait
été donnée le 2 février dernier
mais faute d'avoir pu identifier
l'origine de cette épidémie
le gouvernement avait choisi la
discrétion dont cette situation
extrêmement embarrassantes pour les
gouvernants et pour les responsables qui
consiste à dire nous enquêtons mais à ce
stade
l'enquète ne nous permet pas de dire
d'où vient cette épidémie donc c'est la
plus mauvaise période pour nous à la
faune constate les dégâts et on n'a pas
de réponses aux questions que nous
posons toute la france est touchée 19
départements au total les populations à
risque sont les femmes enceintes les
personnes âgées ou sans défenses
immunitaires
en attendant les résultats de l'enquêté
mercredi elles doivent éviter de
consommer les fromages au lait cru et
les produits de charcuterie ce sont
surtout les rillettes et produit en
gelée qui sont montrés du doigt
le gouvernement vient d'ailleurs de
durcir la réglementation en charcuterie
avec notamment des dates limites de
consommation règle est souvent c'est
aussi un des produits achetés en fin de
la limite de consommation garder un peu
au delà dans des conditions qui sont pas
excellentes
surtout d'ailleurs c'est un certain
nombre de personnes qui ne voient pas
bien clair les dates et c'est donc des
limites de consommation et affichage des
dates en plus grand c'est ce que nous
avons décidé de faire certains
spécialistes vont même plus loin il ne
faut pas se fier aux dates inscrites sur
les emballages car elles ne sont
valables que si la conservation
s'effectue dans des conditions optimales
pas plus de 4 degrés ce qui est rarement
le cas le problème c'est que le pont
batteur lui n'a pas les moyens notamment
en équipement de froid de conserver ses
produits correctement donc il faut que à
l'intérieur de ces dates limites de
consommation le consommateur comme le
produit vite qu'il y ait dans un délai
maximum de quatre jours après l'achat
pour être sûr d'éviter tout risque de
contracter la listériose